[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for another
tip 20:19 interview right now we are
talking come with horses and I'm so
excited I have the team behind the film
here today again you guys know how much
I love this movie huge congratulations
it's really something else wanted to
start with you here because I'm sure
you're getting this all the time and
probably sick of doing it but for
anybody out there who does not know what
come with horns this is about can you
give a brief synopsis so come with
horses it's a sort of emotional crime
thriller about a young boxer whose
loyalties are sort of torn between a
family of criminals that he sort of his
surrogate family and his ex-girlfriend
and young son so much more to explore
beyond that that I highly suggest
everyone check out I was reading up
about you a little bit and I read that
you used to be into rally driving how do
you get from that to directing a movie
yes I used to be a sort of
semi-professional rally driver for a
while but sadly I wasn't good enough in
the end so I did it up until about 2008
and then when that all dried up I was
sort of working an aquarium for a year
thinking what the hell am I going to do
and I took it on my multiple choice quiz
and it told me to be either a librarian
or a filmmaker take filmmaking did that
skill set come in handy at all on this
movie there's a bit no I didn't I didn't
Cosmo there is a car chase in the film
that was a lot of fun to do we only had
a day to do it for the three of you
curious the script crosses your path
what is it about it about each of your
characters that really stands out to you
what is the quality about them that you
could not wait to sink your teeth into
I appreciated the style of the write in
what like it was Joe it was adapted from
a short story the style of the language
was pretty cool because it was stylized
in its own world and it felt like it was
credible within it it was of its world
and that came through on first reading
which is a cool thing to come into
contact with so that was the first thing
I guess yeah and just the general story
I really liked because it was simple but
very complicated and yeah I felt like it
was
something that most people who are alive
could kind of relate to in some way or
another
absolutely I think the thing that I
walked away thinking the most about is
that that's what you think about
everybody else it's like their problem
is simple but to you it's super
complicated and this is a movie that
gives us access to his head and really
understands every single thing coming at
him at the same time and that there's no
easy answers to any of it and
everybody's eating a giant [ __ ] sandwich
and it's really hard to navigate the
good from the bad
yes Barry for you I'm curious did you
get the opportunity to design your
characters look at all cuz like
immediately when he pops on screen he is
just so striking
yeah and originally I wanted to question
mark and decide my head you know we
talked about that didn't we I want to do
something weird like that but was just a
bit too much and but yeah we want we
wanted to make them striking and you
know to stand out a lot you know and and
as if he just you know when it when Nick
described this film to me he wanted this
kind of Punk kind of you know rock kind
of look and so yeah we met we met and
that kind of I mean the costume as well
the costume designer was great as well
so yeah was it was nice to kind of
create that - striking image it's
definitely very effective so I was
reading that the - you didn't really
hang out too much before making the
movie because it did I think usually I
think it was a quote you gave that you
wanted to make it seem like he like arm
was strictly there to kind of be your
right-hand man ya know we did we all
know a little I only mention a few days
before though didn't I Cosmo was an
accident the entire time that we shot so
they like I met arm from the rehearsals
he when I moved back to London and I met
you randomly in like Clapham Junction
and I you were in your own accent it's
like scare the life out of me but yeah
because we did like a couple of days
rehearsal and like my character is of
most scenes that were mine oh yeah with
the Sony yeah and we did like a day
where we went to like a like a bowling -
we go bowling no he's like a like a
jungle gym for
children and we kind of hung out it was
like a family so you're trying to like
builds like core memories because
morning Barry's character do you not get
on at all like what we really think we
didn't hang out we didn't know I really
want to be friends no more force day
which you I gave you like you know I
Nick Nick told me to be kind of you
worried it was pretty hard I had to you
know the character doesn't like it
doesn't doesn't like him names character
that's all like so you know he sees her
as an ops like as an obstacle like in a
way and you know so I we had to kind of
we're all kind of in character you know
because we don't like a couple of
workshops with that Killian who plays
Jack the boy in us and we played like
soccer and he loves soccer Liverpool
Football I think he's back to Liverpool
Emile so with your three characters
struggling through a tough situation and
sometimes of course it's easy to make an
assumption about a person but I think
they all are I don't know about didn't
but maybe they all have a redeeming
quality so what is wrong quality about
your character that you would want to
keep with you after this experience
charm
okay no that's fair that's fair he can
talk his way into and out of most things
I like your simplicity yeah for me I
just like how it's like he's not gonna
get he's not gonna overcome convolute
his thoughts on things it's just like
he's just you know one second to the
next kind of a nut something I could
maybe take a leaf out of the book of the
leaf and take some leaves out of the
book
take the book first of all I think it
was and she's very determined and in
she's white you know cuz at the start of
it she's really trying to get out of the
time that she's in and I think it's the
idea of just being the strength that she
has a whole lot of really big moments
was there any particular day where some
sort of like happy magic came out of a
situation on set where like things
weren't going right or you had to do
something on the fly and all of a sudden
it turned out to be something better
than you ever expected pretty much I
mean you know it was a very it was a
very very quick shoe
you know we had you know we had we had
animals we had car chases where you know
guns and all this sort of stuff so to be
honest every day it felt like you'd look
at the work ahead and you just think are
we ever going to get through it so so
pretty much every day felt kind of
touching I mean what what was you know
the there's a scene towards the end of
the film which is just done in one shot
basically it's an eight-minute take and
that was that was a lot of you know that
was kind of a you know everyone was so
focused and and when we got it and you
know Cosmo didn't Eve did such a great
job with that that that wasn't be the
magic part today was you know lunch
obviously but you know I was if there
was a nice energy on set you know the
Irish crews are very nice as well and
and everyone was treated like it was
like a family and it really was I can
it's just a nice yeah it was small as
well and I think I helps as well you
know a film like this intimate film like
this you need you need a small crew and
so was a nice I think oh yeah we don't
wait what we were filming in Connemara
lovely mountain ranges in the West of
Ireland so they'd go out that the the
the the caterers would go out fishing
during the day while we're filming and
would come back with the catch of the
day or so the unsung heroes on film sets
it makes such a big difference
everyone's well fed you get an hour off
it makes difference yeah well I think
for this film it was like whenever I
signed on today because I knew of Colin
bearish he was the original he'd be
written a story called young skins but
it was like in Ireland it was a
well-known well-known story so I think
when you have independent filmmaking
everyone is there with the incentive of
because they want to be there and they
want to work on that particular project
and everyone wants to give their own
little little piece to it so there is
that family creative bond and also when
you've got a kid on the set people act
better I feel
this is a bit more like moral stance and
and play definitely because Killian was
five years old when he filmed it so he
was only allowed to be on set for five
hours a day but sometimes he'd be in a
scene which would be seven pages long or
something like that it's so kind of sort
of yeah he was so focused he was great
because you just brought up that it was
a quick shoot we play this game on
collide or would you rather all
filmmaking questions and I'm curious to
hear your answer to this one would you
rather have enough time but not enough
money or enough money but not enough
time I think time I'd always love more
time there's never enough time I think
with time you can you can sort of
probably get around a lot of stuff
there's something that there is
something quite nice about when you when
you're up against it yeah yeah I think
the two go hand in that you're cheating
at my game right now it's not like I did
a lot of my short films shot on 16 mil
film and so sometimes you could only do
things in one take because we just
couldn't afford the amount of film stock
and sometimes when you're up against it
that does kind of bring quite a nice
energy as well so I don't know the
answer to that but well you use the time
you had on this one well guys really
congratulations thank you love the film
come with horses keep an eye out for it
also we have to say a special thank you
to our sponsors at Nordstrom Canada
thank you so much for making these
interviews happen do not leave this
video without liking and sharing it and
we'll be back soon with more TIFF
coverage